[Musique]
odon vallet bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france le pas françois
termine donc ce matin une visite de
quatre jours en europe centrale en
slovaquie notamment un pays où la
religion catholique qui est en recul il
s'est adressé à la jeunesse quelle a été
la portée de ce message de son message
comment est-ce qu'il a été reçue en
slovaquie par françois alors il a fait
une demi journée en hongrie et quatre
journées en slovaquie alors c'est
bizarre parce que la slovaquie c'est la
patrie de l'automobile mais c'est aussi
un pays où il ya en gros une majorité de
catholiques une minorité de musulmans et
de protestants alors quand c'est qu' une
grande majorité d'autrefois de
protestants et dans un certain sens on
peut dire qui il était écouté par la
jeunesse il disait la jeunesse au fond
il faut ne pas avoir peur des idées
modernes les jeunes sont tout à fait
d'accord avec lui on a le sentiment
qu'il est beaucoup plus proche des
jeunes que des anciens donc ça ça allait
bien en slovaquie mais en fait le plus
important c'est la demi-journée passée
en gris parce que il ya noté que le
prochain à le cardinal erdo qui est
archevêque de budapest
beaucoup disent que ça pourrait être le
prochain pape il s'est bien entendu avec
jean paul ii qui l'avait créé cardinal
avec benoit 16 et maintenant avec pape
françois alors beaucoup disent que le
pape françois il est pas éternel il a
quand même les sérieux problèmes de
santé sur le plan du moral ça va pas
très fort non plus il a engueulé
littéralement les catholiques
traditionalistes
il a fait une gaffe monumentale en
disant que la loi suisse ne s'était pas
bien mais que la loi de jésus christ
était bien mieux qu'à gaffe alors que
ils n'arrêtent pas de protester contre
l'antisémitisme
certains pensent qu'ils pourraient
pourrait bientôt
dire je vais me reposer un peu et là à
budapest le cardinal a toutes ses
chances un moment justement pour revenir
cette visite en hongrie elle a été
scrutée de très près il rencontrait le
président viktor orban dont le ced très
attaché aux racines chrétiennes dans son
pays et pourtant il une vision opposée
une vision d'europe opposé du pape
franchement qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir
de cette heure je suivais
viktor orban
est devenu très attaché aux racines
chrétiennes
avant il l'était beaucoup moins mais
c'est quoi les racines chrétiennes et la
france on lit les racines chrétiennes
bon et vise le sont pas pleines je pense
que ce qui est important c'est que la
hongrie ça quand même fait partie du
grand empire austro-hongrois
c'est à dire le saint-empire romain
germanique faut jamais l'oublier ça et
en conséquence la hongrie ça demeure un
pays important et faut jamais oublier
non plus que lorsqu'il y avait l'urss et
et les pays de l'est communiste la
hongrie était un petit peu à part la
hongrie est un petit peu plus tolérant
plus ouvert plus et cetera c'est un fait
un trait d'union alors entre l'orient et
l'occident
le papy n'aime pas l'occident et même
pas l'allemagne ils n'aiment pas la
france je n'aime pas l'espagne il n'aime
pas tout ça et pour quelle raison parce
qu'il en a parlé de l'europe il est
revenu sur sur la crise sanitaire avec
ces mots il a pointé du doigt la
nécessité de ne pas s'isoler eni comme
individu ni comme nation finalement qui
s'adressait acquis aux états européens
alors voilà mais lui pour lui le son de
gravité de l'europe c'est un peu plus
vers l'europe de l'est et
l'europe de l'ouest bon et il est fait
des études en allemagne était malheureux
la france il aime pas d'ailleurs il
n'est jamais venu mais là il dit au fond
il ya l'europe ce qui est pas bête du
tout et il pense aussi que
mr dix nations c'est fini il ya un an
j'ai le vatican il est membre de
beaucoup de dan ex de l'onu et il pense
que il a raison sans doute les pays
indépendants c'est fini c'est la france
n'est plus indépendant tout le monde le
sait maurice faure qui a signé le traité
de rome en 1957 m'avait dit le jour où
j'ai signé j'ai compris que la france
indépendante c'était fini et avec de
gaulle pour y croire encore là dans son
voyage en europe de l'est ce que dit au
fond le pape sait nous sommes tous
frères accepter les migrants accepter
les gens qu'ils aient la peau foncée les
yeux
le nationalisme c'est fini et le
christianisme c'est universel voilà ce
qui leur dit et puis plus tôt les idées
jeunes parce que il faut évoluer et être
de son temps autre temps fort pendant ce
voyage en slovaquie c'est la rencontre
avec la communauté juive le pape
françois qui a fait part de deux ça
honteux
notamment par rapport à l'histoire du
pays et l'histoire des catholiques par
rapport à la communauté juive qu'est ce
qu'on peut retenir on s'est compliqué
parce que pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale il y avait une espèce de
gouvernement plus ou moins inféodés aux
nazis qui était théoriquement présidé
par un prêtre qu'on a dit évêques et
puis cardinal et pitié mais en fait
c'est compliqué parce que en slovaquie
ya beaucoup de juifs qui ont échappé au
pire alors qu'en hongrie c'était atroce
ces pros lors le pays qui a le plus
souffert a aussi dit m moi je pense que
c'est important qu'ils parlent de
l'antisémitisme maintenu pour réparer sa
gaffe d'ailleurs à propos des loisirs il
et puis ça signifie quelque part que
antisémitisme s'est mis ça veut dire
quoi c'est d'ailleurs en gains l'arabe
est une langue sémitique c'est ne pas
avoir
d'un priori contre
les enfants d'abraham puisque que vous
soyez musulmans juifs ou chrétiens vous
êtes les enfants d'abraham marie mère de
jésus c'est myriam en arabe mais c'est
pareil rappelez-vous la très belle
chanson de marie myriam qui a le grand
prix de l'eurovision en 1970 chef comme
un nuage peut-être cette dernière
question la slovaquie jean paul 2 il y
avait été il s'y était rendu en août on
connaît le poids géopolitique de jean
paul ii aujourd'hui par françois est ce
qui là encore ce poids qu'est ce qu'il
pèse
dans le monde le fameux françois
aujourd'hui alors il pèse moins pour une
bonne raison et elle éprouve françois et
les antis françois il a autant d'ennemis
que d'amis l'église catholique est
profondément divisé on avait eu une
sorte d' enthousiasme lorsqu'il a été
élu les journées mondiales de la
jeunesse à rio-de-janeiro mais
maintenant le catholicisme une vire un
petit peu quand même plus un droit qui y
compris en france d'ailleurs d'une
certaine façon il ya une reprise
d'ailleurs de la conviction catholique
dans beaucoup de pays dont la france
mais d'un catholicisme traditionnel
alors que c'est pas celui des pâtes
françois je dirais que le pape françois
paradoxalement plus il est avec les
idées jeunes plus ils affrontent des
jeunes qui sont conservateurs parce
qu'il y en a aussi regardé en france 1
il y en a beaucoup qui sont dans les
dents ce qui défile le samedi là chez
les catholiques d'extrême droite 1 je
sais les anciens de fillon par le pape
il est pas bien à l'aise mais c'est un
homme qui a un courage extraordinaire
qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas très
saint père bravo pour votre courage mais
bon votre successeur on verra merci
beaucoup au don valley d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin sur rtl france
je le rappelle vous êtes historien des
religions et médium
[Musique]